[Music]
in this video today we will take a look
into the other monsterverse titans and
which side will they be
on if there was ever kind of a godzilla
vs gong civil war
of course the movie will feature the two
tyrants battling each other for
dominance
and other reasons but what about the
other super species
that exist alongside them it wouldn't be
great to say that they would not even be
appearing in the movie at least some of
the older titans
and even the new ones that haven't had
any screen time should be
shown in the upcoming movie behemoth has
a leaked toy image that would most
probably mean
that he would be there in the movie and
so would warbat
and the hellhawks so let's dig in and
dive into the probable allegiances
the other titans will have in this
battle of the super powers
let's do it so titans are ancient
gigantic creatures studied by the
scientific
organization known as monarch while
monarch
initially designates any such creature
it studies as
massive unidentified terrestrial
organisms once they are formally
identified
they are then classified as titans many
of these titans respond to an alpha
a tyrant which has cemented itself as
the strongest of the creatures
typically by defeating the previous
alpha as of 2019
there are 19 tyrants discovered by
monarch there are two types
that protect the titans and the
destroyers in the end of kotm
sila behemoth methuselah rodan and the
queen muta arrive and bow down to
godzilla as their new alpha
and as the film ends news clippings show
a newly discovered
mothra egg titans beginning to converge
to skull island
a mysterious forest blooming at the
sahara desert and ancient paintings
displaying godzilla
battling kong so there's a lot we need
to catch up on the titans in this
upcoming movie
don't worry we will get to the topic at
hand first we need to cement ourselves
in monster verse lore
see why this question arises is that
kong was never seen heeding the calls of
either ghidorah
or godzilla and he is in his own way an
alpha
the king of skull island and since in
the end of the movie we see news
clippings
that the titans are heading off the
skull island this doesn't seem to be
just a coincidence
titans aren't savages animals that just
live to eat and eat to live
they are sentient creatures that have
existed for hundreds of millions of
years
and if you compound all that diamond to
a near immortal monster
it would have the unspoken wisdom and
intelligence of the ages
which now leads me to a relatively new
born gong
and its new alpha status this might
explain the reason as to why the titans
are going off to skull island
kong is relatively new on the world
stage but his ancestors were not
and it is now confirmed that there was
an ancient battle between the
members of gong and godzilla species
these titans now sense the presence of a
new alpha kong individual
one that is capable of standing up
against godzilla i will say it again
the titans bowed down to an alpha and
since they didn't really resist the call
of ghidorah
it means that they weren't too keen on
joining sides with godzilla either
there could have been major titan
politics back in the day when the war
between kongs and good jiras
took place some might have gone to
kong's camp while others to godzilla's
and others might have been neutral could
this
hint on a major titan battle thousands
of years ago
this would be a prelude to the events of
godzilla vs gong
since they have already hinted at
monster walls that would be the
foundation of this movie
let's see the synopsis once again the
new updated one by legendary and warner
bros
here's what it says legends collide in
godzilla versus coal
as these mythic adversaries meet in a
spectacular battle for the ages
with the fate of the world hanging in
the balance gong
and his protectors undertake a perilous
journey to find his true home
but they unexpectedly find themselves in
the path of an enraged godzilla
cutting a swath of destruction across
the world the epiclash between the two
titans
instigated by unseen forces is only the
beginning
of a mystery that lies deep within the
core of the earth
what did i tell you okay so let's see
which titans would most definitely be on
godzilla's side
first one methuselah this titan is first
of all a reptilian kaiju that was
discovered in germany
he bowed down to godzilla and king of
the monsters and has no specific loyalty
to any other kaiju but the alpha
second silla as an aquatic kaiju that
shares the habitat with godzilla
it wouldn't be wise at all to challenge
godzilla especially with
his dominance of the seas and being
isolated from the other camp
it would be an easy kill for the g-man
therefore cilla would most probably side
with godzilla
third warbat as was seen in the trailer
of godzilla vs kong
the warbats were hostile towards kong
and most probably his species
so it would make sense that it would be
with godzilla in any such battle
the skull crawlers of course are enemies
of kong
and just by that they would be on the
team of godzilla
now going to the other corner kong's
team of titans would consist of
firstly bermuda queen since it is an
ancient rival species of godzilla
and although it bowed down to him in the
end of king of the monsters
it would most likely change sights in
the case of a battle
that has a challenging titan since the
death of godzilla
at the end of the battle would allow it
to lay her spose inside him
and therefore create a new generation of
miros that would take over the world
secondly behemoth
another titan that was seen bowing down
to godzilla as alpha
but the producers originally had a
different backstory for this mammoth
sloth gian he was supposed to be a war
beast that was
chained up and shackled by an ancient
society and used
to go to war that's the meaning for
wobbies and
the most and the cute part of this
backstory is that
it likes belly rubs and being groomed by
kong
so mammalian titans unite i guess
now let's go to the third cam the
neutral titans
which is like the non-alignment movement
during the cold war
okay mothra's hatchling firstly if it
was ever to come out in the future of
the monsterverse
would definitely not take any sights
even though it was said that this
creature this titan
shares a symbiotic link with godzilla
but i think mortar's existence is to
deter and fight against destroyer titans
and threats to the planet like ghidorah
kong as a protector titan himself would
not be viewed with hostility
by mothra which is why it would sit this
one out
secondly rodan the fire demon will not
be
joining any sites or sharing any
allegiances to any of the
two protected islands since it is a
destroyer it will also be missing from
either camps and
he was supposedly able to challenge
other alpha titans
in the original storyline and since his
loyalty is deemed
questionable at the least starscream
this flying kaiju would most definitely
be roosting over another volcano
and watching netflix instead of joining
in another war
he could although he could challenge
kong however in the future
if gom was ever to beat godzilla which
would be a great idea for a movie
gong vs rodan so i know that this isn't
a perfect list of the titans that would
side with either kong or godzilla
therefore you can put down your own list
down in the comments section below make
it a descriptive list
that will describe which titans will
side with who
and why and so with that we come to the
end of this video
do like for support smash that subscribe
button
and also slap that notification bell for
regular updates
until the next one take care fam